so you've mentioned before about the big
dream in the little dream and I think
that's really an interesting thought and
I'm thinking about that from my own life
but in terms of an actor's type you've
said before that you're you have a type
if you play a lawman or something
similar you know what if an actor isn't
necessarily happy with their type and
they've come to this city with a big
dream of who they think their type
should be but that's not what the
audience tells the more casting director
tells them that that's a really hard
question and the reason it's hard is
because you you have to so believe in
what you are or at least be willing to
to withstand the struggle of that so I
would hate to say you know reinvent
yourself into a new type because what
their great gift is we might not see
might when you first said that my my
first inclination was go back to New
York and get on the stage where you have
the room to create whatever type your
instincts take you to you know when
Dustin Hoffman did Midnight Cowboy they
they thought he was playing joke buck
his friends oh wow you took that role
Joe Buck no no I'm playing ratso Rizzo
what yeah yeah I'm walking here I'm
walking you know
sorry Dustin that's not a very good
imitation but but he chose something
that so stretched him in another
direction that and you know he's an
extraordinary character man but they
would have pigeon told him it's the
nature of things we you know there's a
tremendous amount of risk that exists in
our business for all at every level
making a film financing a film being in
a film distributing a film reviewing a
film does the film get legs does it not
get legs this it's just a tremendous
amount of risk so there's there's a
default switch or an escape where people
try to reduce risk
you know they do it with me I get hired
I think a lot of times because they go
oh neo can do that you know it's not
always the most compelling role that I'm
going to do but it's going to pay the
mortgage and and so I in response to
that that question look you can you can
you can study you can reinvent you can
figure out a way and I think people that
do that through the course of their
careers to show another facet of the
diamond oh they've seen this let's try
to show them this you know but if it's a
question of going and exploring what
that type is I would say go to New York
and and get on the stage and just work
and build a community and embrace them
and and the business will find you
someone they'll find their their type is
that through a casting director telling
them their agent it's usually what you
get cast at you know there's an old
saying they won't cast you for what you
can't do they'll always cast you for it
you can do and so some of those early
roles they see something you go yeah and
so there's the opportunity now with the
opportunity also comes the beginnings of
the bottleneck narrowing so for yourself
if you don't want the bottleneck to be
very narrow then outside of the business
you have to stretch into other
characters you have to do that at home
or do it in an acting class or do it on
the stage so that you keep that thread
taut because what what tends to happen
is that it's once you're in and that and
they've sort of decided okay this is
what you're reliable that you can you
can lose your
connection and affinity and wherewithal
for that stuff so I would say mm-hmm you
got to be kind of mindful and vigilant
to keep that out
you